[Music]
this is one of the common areas where we
come to do body recoveries
uh
it it's the the river's low
so
the body the people drown
upriver
float down and end up in this low-lying
areas
either on the mexican side or on the
american side
[Music]
two weeks ago we had
four people that drowned in one day
now the next day we had another drowning
the very next day we had another
drowning so right there
you know you're looking at six people
that drown so that would overwhelm a
facility or or a morgue this is what's
what's causing all this this this uh
burden on the on the mortuaries so
there's so many
uh bodies being recovered that the
morticians are asking for assistance
and we've actually
loaned them a refrigerated truck to
store
all of those bodies
the rio grande river is very funny
sometimes you you'll be walking in an
area where the water will never go above
your knee
but all of a sudden you'll have a drop
of about 10-12 feet
if you're carrying a baby
you're going to go down 10-12 feet with
that baby we had babies not too long ago
drowned
we had a three-month-old baby we had a
three-year-old baby brother that passed
away the uncle was trying to cross he
fell into a deep hole in the river
let go of the babies the babies drown
i would like to see the the federal
government jump in and help out
in whatever way they can so that could
be alleviated if they could at least
stop this migration that would be
awesome
i don't see any end in sight
i think washington needs to do something
about it eagle pets is a small city like
i said we have
four ambulances
and two reserve trucks of course we have
private ambulances
that work within the city
but
those four trucks they get overwhelmed
every single day
in my career
in the last year or two
i had never seen so many drownings uh
like we're seeing right now we we
when i started we used to do
maybe 12 a year
now we're doing
one a day 30 a month these are young
young gentlemen
young women that
are seen more than
any normal person would see in a
lifetime
i mean if you think about it it's almost
like a war zone
it's almost like a war zone
one thing that i would ask
[Music]
any government official
to come and see what's going on
down here in the in in eagle pass it's
not what some people
say
is happening i mean you've
we've got we've got a big issue here in
eagle pass